Alhamdulillah.
[Silence]
Allah. for
imari.
Hebell.
And so
says
that
took
the prophet sallall.aii wasallam to her
cousin, her paternal cousin
Abd
and he was a Christian man. It accepted
Christianity and as we've mentioned
before
and she said
listen to what has happened to and she's
speaking to the prophet about the
prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam.
He said, "This is the same angel
moose that Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
sent down upon Misam
and
he recognized that this was Jirel
because Jirelam
he has he is the One who was
commissioned by Allah from amongst the
angels
commissioned by Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala to be his liaison between him and
his prophets and messengers from amongst
mankind.
He is his ambassador.
And so even Mus Alisam received Jirel
and every single prophet and messenger
received Jirelam.
And Jirelam
comes to the prophets and messengers
with a very clear and distinct message.
And so
the prophet sallallah.aihi wasallam told
what had happened and he recognized him
immediately.
He recognized him from the
scriptures and from the
as we mentioned before he was a very old
man. He had become blind in his later
age and he was triilingual. He spoke
Arabic and Hebrew and Aramaic and he was
a skilled translator. And so he
recognized Gibl
immediately and he said,
he said, "I wish that I had more life
ahead of me so that I could be alive to
witness the time and be with you
at the moment when your people drive you
out of your own city and in your own
land and he was very beloved to the
people before this.
Now here we want to take a moment and
think about something. The prophet
sallallah.aii wasallam was loved by his
people
prior to the message of Islam. He was
loved by Abu Jah who was referred to as
Abul Hakim. He was loved by Abu Lahab.
He was loved by
Abu Sufyan.
He was beloved to all of his people.
But that love
was not a legislative love.
Loving the prophet sallall.aii wasallam
is an act of worship. Correct?
However, that was not an act of worship
from them. They loved the prophet
sallall.aii wasallam but they loved him
in a natural way. Not because he was a
messenger. They loved him because they
liked his character. He was nice to
them. He had good character. He had
good a very good
history with them. And so that's why
they liked him. It's not because he was
a messenger. The only time loving the
prophet sallall.aii alaihi wasallam is
of consequence with Allah in the
hereafter is loving him because he is a
messenger
and the true test of loving the prophet
sallallahu alaii wasallam is not found
in proclamations
proclaiming your love for him saiam
or making continuous proclamations
rather it is in following him and
adhering to his sunnah and keeping his
legacy alive even if only in your own
life. This is the true love of the
prophet sallall.aii wasallam. The
prophet sallallah.aii alaihi wasallam
said or Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala said
to him
say if you truly love Allah the pro if
you truly love Allah then follow me and
Allah will love you. We love the prophet
sallall.aii wasallam in a very different
way than the mushri love the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam. We love him
in a legislative way. We love him
because he is a messenger.
Their love of him was because of how he
made them feel before he was a prophet
and messenger.
And so many of them continued to love
him in a natural way but they hated him
in a legislative way. They hated him
because he was a messenger saiam.
And so the prophet sallallah.aii
wasallam asked
he was surprised by this. He was
shocked. He said, "Are my people really
going to drive me out of my land, of my
home?" He said,
he said, "No man has ever brought before
the message that you are now bringing to
us except that he will have fierce,
vicious enemies."
He will have enemies. And the word is
And what this means and articulates is
that he will have a multitude of enemies
that will be from many aspects and
many angles. Enemies from opposition.
Enemies from within. Enemies from those
who claim to be in his ranks saiam.
Why did they why does he have enemies?
Why?
The reason he has enemies is not because
of his character. Is not because of
his personal issues with them. The
reason he has enemies is because what he
brings puts a damper on whatever it is
they think that he is now standing in
their way to.
When you stand between people and their
desires, you will have enemies.
That's the reason a lot of times we
imagine that the prophets and messengers
are fought against because their enemies
truly believed that they weren't
prophets. That's not the case. No one
who meets a prophet or messenger is ever
left that meeting in doubt on whether or
not that was a prophet that they spoke
to. Because every prophet and messenger
is given miracles. Every prophet and
messenger falls follows a particular
creed and ethos that fits in perfectly
with the entirety of the chain of
prophets and messengers and fit
perfectly within the pattern.
No one had any
any true doubt
that he was a messenger.
Abu Jah Abuab they knew he was a prophet
and messenger.
But the issue is not about truth and
they profess this
and all the enemies of the prophets and
messengers. They profess we love the
truth. We are vanguards of the truth.
All we want is the truth. We love Allah.
Some of them even claim love to the
other messengers, the Jews of Medina and
the Christians
from Yemen in the prophet
sallallah.aii wasallam's time and the
Christians from Najan. They claimed and
professed to love
the prophets of Allah to love
to love
and they would memorize their stories
but they don't want
anything standing in the way of their
comfort what they find comfortable
whatever it is whether it be gambling or
whether it be addiction or whether it be
their position.
Pharaoh was most frightened of Musam
because of what? Because of his
position.
Haman was most frightened of MS's
message. Because of his position, his
position as the general of the armies.
And they they reject Islam not because
of Islam itself not because there's
anything wrong with the message but
because of the implications of the
message.
If I accept this message therefore
I can't do this anymore or I have to do
this now etc. And so what are the
driving forces?
If we were to boil them all down and
look at all of the prophets that are
mentioned in the Quran, all of their
dialogue with their people, all of
the debates and all of the enmity and
all of the arguments, if we were to boil
them all down, what are the pillars of
Kufur?
Because we have pillars of iman, right?
We have pillars of Islam.
When a person has these traits, they are
a Muslim. And the more these traits are
embodied by any person, the more this
person's Islam is solidified.
So we have pillars of Islam. What are
the pillars of disbelief?
Allah mentions in his book and
he says that the pillars of disbelief
are four. There are four pillars of
disbelief. What does that mean? Pillars
of disbelief. Meaning the driving forces
that drive people to disbelieve
after the message is given to them and
after they are shown signs and miracles
and the truth cuts deep and they know
that this is the truth from Allah. What
causes them then to turn away? There's
four pillars, four ultimate reasons.
And every single person or people who
rejected a prophet or messenger, it is
one of or a collection of these four
pillars. So these are referred to as the
pillars of disbelief.
There are four pillars to disbelief.
number one al
number two.
Number three al
so we have first al which is anger. It
doesn't mean just being angry. That's
not what is meant here. What is meant is
everything that comes from aggression,
whether it be patriotism
or tribalism that causes them to reject
the prophets and messengers. This falls
into the category of what? Of anger.
Right? The second is desire.
The third is a or
now notice when they say
that it is jealousy and envy and the
fourth is arrogance.
These are the four pillars of disbelief.
Why do people enter the hellfire? Every
single soul that is damned by Allah was
damned because of one or more of these
four reasons. Put all the arguments
aside. Put all of the if this is true
then this and all the alleged logical
arguments and all of the debates and
everything. Put that all aside. It boils
down to what? One of these four things.
the issue of aggression
or anger or rebellion. Number two,
arrogance, number three, jealousy,
number four, desire.
He says
that anger prevents a person from being
just.
It esc.
When a person has any kind of aggression
or a kind of a will to harm or a will
to rebel or enmity,
it it causes a person to not be able to
be just and be fair anymore.
Number two, jealousy prevents a person
from desiring good for others.
and desire
and pleasure. This prevents a person
from
freeing himself for the worship of Allah
because the worship of Allah is not
always comfortable. Sometimes it's
uncomfortable, sometimes it is
inconvenient, etc. And so when a person
follows his desires too much, anything
that takes him out of his comfort zone,
this is something that he will innately
reject.
And number four,
arrogance,
which prevents a person from accepting
the truth.
Prevents a person from accepting the
truth.
So often times and this is a
misunderstanding people have and we'll
end with this. A misunderstanding that
people have is that when a person
rejects the truth they are they are
genuinely confused or they are genuinely
unconvinced
that this is a prophet or a messenger
and that is not the case. They know that
they are dealing with a messenger. Even
Abu Jahel
Abu Jahel he said that the reason he
rejected the prophet sallall.aii alaihi
wasallam's message is because
of his arrogance and tribalism prevents
him from adhering to the lead of anyone
from Beni Hashim
which is the prophet's tribe sallallahu
alaihi wasallam
they said since when are we followers of
beni hashim we will never accept him not
because he doesn't know he's a
Messenger. Abu Jahel said, "I swear that
I know he is a messenger, but since when
are we followers of Beni Hashim? Wall,
we will never follow him or accept him."
And so where was his end? In the pits of
hell. Because of one or more of these
pillars.
forham.
[Silence]
Alhamdulillah.